I'm ready to retest for some of my my gut permeability issues. I took a test from a KBMO.
Yeah. I don't know if I've heard of them and had some elevated Candida and LPS.
Yeah. And do you have a different a test that you would like to kind of monitor that on going
length? Should I stick with the KBMO? Can you get that through Rupa for me or?
Well, if you want to stick with the KBMO, you could just buy it, get it right off our store.
So we do add people that order the KBMO. No, I do like that test because it's less expensive than
the Cyrex. But as far as quality tested, it's not as quality as the Cyrex. The Cyrex tests for
IGG and IGGA antibodies, which the KBMO doesn't. And the Cyrex tests for multiple different foods
that are cooked and uncooked when the protein is changed in that particular food, which that gives
a little bit more detail too. As far as having lipopolysaccharides and evidence of Candida,
when we do oat testing, that's organic acid testing on people. In variable, people come up
positive for Candida. Now one could argue that everybody has, one could argue that majority of people
have some level of Candida. Cyrex labs came up with a Candida vulnerability test that is a
standalone test that tests whether how bad a person's Candida is. That's extremely accurate. And
I've had people run that test that showed positive of the oat test for Candida. And then we run that
test and it was negative. So I, that's not uncommon what I've heard in the industry is that
everybody's got some level of Candida, the majority people do. But how much of that is really affecting
them is there's only a small percentage of people that are in that category. So does it mean that
you should have necessarily addressed the Candida? I'm not saying that. But does everybody have to
go on to caprylic acid and that's your number one help for Candida? I don't think so. Should everybody be
working on trying to heal their gut with different gut healing things? That would, I think, be a better
approach than trying to quote unquote kill Candida because Candida is an opportunistic organism. And if
you heal good blue, then Candida is going to go back into balance. Remember, Candida is
is part of your normal flora as well. It's just what it's out of balance. It's like H. Pylora. H. Pylora
is actually part of your normal flora. But it's what it's out of balance that it becomes a problem.
Now lipo polysaccharides are a little bit different. If you're positive with lipo polysaccharides,
that is suggestive of bacteria in the gut that were gram negative bacteria that can damage
the gut wall even farther. And you can get not only so typically what's thought about what leaky
gut is the cells themselves are separated. So the tight junctions of the cells, the tightness
each cell up to each other is called a tight junction. That tight junction is loosened. And then
you are absorbing things that you should never absorb peptides of proteins that should never have
gotten through because the cells are somewhat separated and peptides can get through that separation
and get into the gut cavity and get into the bloodstream. If that's the case, that's typically what's
thought about leaky gut. But if you have lipo polysaccharides present, they can actually damage the cell
wall itself of the endothelial cell, epithelial cells that lie in the gut. And if you have damage
of that cell wall, then you have things that are literally going through the cell that are getting
into the bloodstream. So that's even further damage of the gut. So again, what do you do if you have
lipo polysaccharides, do you try to curate or bind the lipo polysaccharides to get rid of them?
No, you're dealing with trying to heal the gut. Okay, so you're doing gut healing procedures,
things like slippery elm and teclisterized licorice and marshmallow and
fiber and all these different things. And then you're also looking at what could have been a
production factor of lipo polysaccharides could have been just an infection that a person had.
But it's quite often, if it's a chronic thing, you look at H. Pylori or you look at Lyme disease.
So those are your, the number one cause of increased lipo polysaccharides is
Lyme disease because Borrelia spits out a ton of lipo polysaccharides. H. Pylori does as well,
but more on a chronic basis, it's not going to be as higher levels. But any lipo polysaccharides can
damage epithelial cells, can damage endothelial cells, those are the cells that lie in your arteries and
can damage blood-brained barrier cells, the astrocytes. So the astrocytes make up your blood-brained
barrier and the astrocytes can be damaged by lipo polysaccharides. So an adult is supposed to have
an intact blood-brained barrier and when that breaks down, then we're getting things more things
crossing the blood-brained barrier causing microglial primate and causing, you know, just overall brain
inflammation and then possibly antibodies to neural tissue. So um, how do you ultimately address
this? Well, you're going back to trying to heal, keeping a gut healing protocol. Well, part of a gut
healing protocol is to make sure you're not eating foods that are inflammatory to you. And the most
common things are going to be dairy and gluten, eggs that are not so much eggs are so A and
and then testing for, you know, like possibly eating hidden foods that are inflammatory, if you're
having problems, you're test for those. So, you know, on a less expensive test to eat the KBMO,
on a more accurate test to eat a CyRex 10. But then there's another test, gut,
zoom or test, when they first came out, they were less expensive, but they're about the same prices
as the CyRex test now. So I think CyRex is, CyRex is my preferred test. I think it's the most accurate.